more than 2000 homes and businesses have
been damaged or destroyed
before-and-after pictures show the
aftermath in one part of Santa Rosa
that's north of San Francisco an entire
fire station burned to the ground and a
building at the Signorelli estate
vineyard in Napa was ruined that
vineyard is just one of at least 16
wineries damaged or destroyed in the
Napa Sonoma area the region is known for
producing some of the finest vintages in
the world even the grape vines that
escaped the flames can still be damaged
by smoke here
Maria Billie era material is that
Paradise Ridge winery which burned down
in the fires
Mireya good morning good morning a lot
of wineries have been unable to assess
the damage because there are still
wildfires going on nearby keeping them
from their properties as you can see the
family that owns the Paradise Ridge
Winery came back to complete and utter
destruction in fact where I'm seeing
right now is the path of grapes used to
take before they headed in to this
burned out building where the wine used
to be made a mess it came off the
ceiling huh few structures at the
Paradise Ridge Winery survived this was
a main winemaking area the tasting room
the production building and the Events
Center all went up in flames Sunday
these tanks are all full of solving them
Blanc nearly a hundred thousand bottles
of wine and the entire 2017 harvest gone
winemaker Dan Barr with the wines
beautiful just through Sunday Saturdays
went through and tasted the moon and and
it was you know proud moment the
family-run business was started in 1978
Rene BIC and his sister Sonya are second
generation owners our family's house
survived but we had employees losing
houses and losing everything what does
this mean for their employment status
you know the wildfires are sweeping
through the Napa and Sonoma Valleys
during the end of the harvest season
this is what's left over from a fire
that was here Luis Perdue founder of
wine industry insight says grapes not
destroyed by the fires could be tainted
by the smoke it would be in the flavor
of the wine
absolutely and people can notice that oh
it's very noticeable he also said the
industry might be headed for a minor
recession facing a wine shortage at a
loss of tourism dollars at least in the
short term it's not open for business
now it won't be open for business until
the fires are out things are assessed
and people who can get around freely at
Paradise Ridge the flames came all the
way up to the vineyards gates but the
most prized grapevines were somehow
spared silver lining is the vineyards
next year we should have a should be
able to harvest grapes that is a silver
lining yeah Julie you got to find
something replacing destroyed grapevines
isn't cheap it could take anywhere from
fifty to a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars on top of that it could take
three to five years for these vines to
produce any sort of commercially viable
crop Nora well it's sad to hear Maria
thank you so much